question and she can prove them to you
in real time uh which is also the
subject of of her
talk thanks that a very awesome
introduction just uh basically
summarizes my talk so ask me question no
just kidding okay so um it's really a
pleasure to be here and share my
thoughts about delegated Quantum
computation uh so this is the generic
scenario we're looking at we have
a uh party here will call a client it
has a input row and wants to evaluate a
Quantum channel on the input row and
this will be done via an interactive
process with a server uh in general a
Quantum server and um will allow
multiple rounds of
interaction so right off the bat there's
some trivial solutions that we'll want
to eliminate in order to focus our
discussion on something
meaningful the first solution is that
the client does the computation herself
so she actually has a full quantum
computer or she's able to evaluate this
particular Quantum map um and she
doesn't actually need the server so we
will eliminate this by limiting the
computational power of the client um one
extreme limit as we've discussed already
this morning is having the client
completely classical or maybe we'll have
some intermediate
um conditions that will that will apply
on the client just to maybe limit the
quantum operations that she can
perform and this will be a requirement
you know otherwise the discussion is
kind of trivial so we're always going to
have some sort of limitation on the
client secondly we have a bit more of a
cryptographic flavor um of something
that could be going on so what if the
server just outputs garbage so maybe the
server it could be deviating from the
protocol or maybe the actually the
honest protocol says output garbage
don't actually evaluate the channel so
we want to eliminate this possibility
also and one way of doing that is to
require some verifiability of the result
so that the client even though she can't
perform this Quantum map has a way to
verify that the output is
correct a related concept has to do with
privacy so uh a trivial protocol uh in
this context would be that the client
just sends her input to the server in
the clear so she takes row and sends it
to the server the server does the
quantum map and returns it um that could
be fine but it's kind of trivial uh in
order to uh eliminate this possibility
will enforce a privacy constraint so
somehow the server should learn nothing
learn nothing we'll formalize that later
from the interaction with the client and
this also touches on on Computing on
encrypted data so that the uh we could
see that this input rule would be
encrypted before before sending it over
to the client uh to the
server and um two and three are
related uh for now we'll just say that
we'll pick one of these conditions in
order to um focus the discussion
um all known
protocols that uh Implement
verifiability of the result so there are
known protocols to do these things by
the way I'll tell you about them later
all known protocols that provide
verifiability also happen to provide
privacy and this is not a coincidence I
don't think so at least because we know
that in the case of delegating the
identity function so just uh
authentication we know that um
verifiability implies
privacy um but there are protocols that
provide privacy
only and just a little note that we'll
uh most of the time we'll require that
both parties run in polinomial time so
both parties are
efficient uh this talk will be separated
into two into two parts the first part
is about an overview applications of
delegating Quantum computation
perspectives open questions and then the
second part will'll get more technical
of methods to perform delegated Quantum
computation so the first application is
well to delegate a Quantum computation
so just you know there's there's nothing
uh it's exactly what we've defined so
far here I have a picture where uh to
use one of the modern buzzword we have
some Cloud quantum computer and uh we
have these remote clients wanting to
perform Quantum computations so this is
really relevant and given the current
technological difficulty in building
quantum computers uh we can imagine that
when they are available they might be
scarce and they might also uh be
remotely accessible so maybe they'll
allow clients to query them um and uh
perform computations for these
clients so with the delegated Quantum
computation we could the clients could
delegate these computations while
remaining uh while keeping their privacy
and while also ensuring a verifiability
so that they can check that the
computation is
correct uh this will be specific methods
to do this will be the focus on the
second part of this talk so I'm not
going to go into naming naming par
particular papers that do this Etc at
this
point okay uh second application would
be proofs and interactive proofs which
we've already encountered um this
morning uh from my bias point of view
much of complexity theory is about
delegating computations right so if you
have uh NP for instance um it's the set
of decision problems for which the yes
instances have efficiently verifiable
proofs so the delegation here is that uh
the witness is found it can be found by
a remote resource in this case it would
have to or in the most General case
would be um infinitely powerful but uh
the remote resource the server would
generate the witness and then the
witness can be efficiently verified by
the
client so um this is also generalized
when we talk about interactive proofs
which is an interactive process of
verification
um and um qpip as we've already seen uh
is this class of problems in this case
we'll limit the server to be a Quantum
polinomial time and uh we'll ask for
interactive proof between an almost
classical verifier and an efficient
Quantum
prover
so um the first
implication uh is pretty obvious if you
have a delegated Quantum computation
protocol then you have a Quantum Pro or
interactive proof with the same
parameters so depending on the power
that you've given the client the same
power will be required here in the in
the qpip interactive
proof um however the uh other
implication um isn't clear or at least
I'm pretty sure doesn't hold so a q uh
delegated Quantum computation works on
Quantum information so for instance if
you want to verify a Quantum coin this
is a fundamentally Quantum problem and
you need to be able to process the
quantum information in a delegated way
um and qpip works on classical decision
problems so um it's not you don't get
the implication in the other
direction and um the open problem that
we've already discussed is uh would
every problem in bqp admit a Quantum
impr inter proof with a fully classical
verifier so so again this would be that
a mere mortal like me would be able to
uh interact with a Quantum server and um
be convinced of this uh uh decision
problem and there are known
Solutions but they always kind of find a
workaround and the workaround first of
all is um to use an almost classical
verifier so for instance a verifier that
can that can process access and
communicate a constant and number of
cubits or to um use a classical verifier
but use multiple Quantum provs that are
um assumed to be to not communicate so
in the case of multiple provs it's it's
really neat you can uh kind of cross
interrogate them so use the fact that
they can't communicate to um to uh
improve the power of your verification
mechanism so continuing with uh
interactive proofs and relationship with
delegated Quantum
computation another application is uh to
De quantize a proof system so de
quantizing means like removing the
quantum from a proof system and this has
been done in the context of uh mult
Quantum multipro interactive proof so
there's this class
qip which is a fully Quantum class so
both parties the verifier and the provs
the multiple provs are all Quantum and
um it uh it's been shown that actually
it's not necessary to have a Quantum
verifier in this case we can assume that
the verifier is classical and that all
messages exchanged are classical and
that leaves us with the class MIP star
which is multipro interactive proofs
where the provs share
entanglement so that's the quantum
portion that's left in that interactive
proof and in order to prove this result
uh it the the method is to go through a
protocol for delegated Quantum
computation so the uh verifier which
initially is quantum can uh delegate all
its Quantum power to uh one or multiple
um or to a multiple number of the provs
in this interactive proof therefore we
get that you can remove the quantum
power for the
verifier and the significance of this is
that it simplifies the landscape so in
complexity Theory there's like a lot of
complexity classes and uh the main
question is you know all they are they
equal or what's a relationship ship
between the classes and proving that two
classes are equal just simplifies
everything and makes life hopefully a
little bit
easier
and
um maybe only remotely related is a a
current a big open question that I'm
sure we'll hear more about um this
afternoon and uh is it this afternoon
Toma that you're giving your talk I
think so yes and in the yeah we'll hear
a lot more about this certainly um is
the relationship between the class MIP
which is multi-pro ractive proofs uh
just purely classical and MIP star which
is multipro ractive proofs with
entanglement so the um open question is
does entanglement have any positive use
in the context of these interactive
proof so it been shown recently that MIP
is contained an MIP star and this
question is about you know the other
direction are they equal or are they
different and uh you know I don't know
maybe just thinking about this equality
might help in solving
this okay uh continuing again with
interactive proofs so there's really a
lot of relationship between delegated
and interactive proofs is uh what um you
know maybe the the main one of the
um uh big open questions that kind of
links pretty much all the talks given
during this entire semester is the
Quantum PCP conjecture um again from my
by point of view I see it as delegation
to the extreme so um there's many
embodiments of the PCP conjecture and um
they are very well uh exposed in the
survey paper um that's already been
mentioned I think and uh the one I want
to highlight is the Quantum PCP version
uh that has an interactive proof
flavor so it says that for any language
in qma so qma is kind of the quantum
analy of NP there exists a polinomial
Time Quantum verifier which acts on the
classical input string as well as this
witness sigh so this usually comes from
the approver of course um as well as a
Quantum state of polinomial polinomial
number of cubits such that the verifier
acces only a constant number of cubits
from the witness and decides
acceptance so why the reason I say this
is delegation to the extreme is that the
prover here uh sorry the verifier is
really computationally weak it only
accesses really small portion of the
proof and is still able to
decide okay another application uh
verifying quantum
mechanics um again this has been kind of
touched on um already but uh to go maybe
a little to a little bit more
detail given a black box or Quantum
system that you've purchased or maybe
your friend claims that they're Quantum
or something uh how can you know that
this is true how can you know that this
is a Quantum system uh and in particular
the big problem is we can't predict the
output of a Quantum computation uh in in
the most General case because we're just
polom bounded classical people here um
and this this touches the scientific
method that uh of predict and verify
seems not to apply anymore in the
quantum
regime but there's
hope and here's a little example
consider factoring so um somebody might
build a a large Quantum system that can
Factor um product of large
primes well there's an efficient method
to verify the solution right maybe we
can't predict ahead of time what the
solution will be but once the solution
is given then it's easy to to multiply
the two uh claimed factors and to see if
that that gives me the initial
input so uh in this case we did not
predict the outcome but we predicted the
outcome of a verification process on the
output so it's almost like the
scientific method so can you explain why
can't you predict I mean if
you sample two primes you multip them oh
okay yes so if I had sampled the two
primes ahead of time multiplied them
given that to the Quant computer thanks
yes so that in that case I I chose the
primes to start with so I can predict
them but if I initially just chosen a
random
number if I don't know ahead of time
yeah it's not why that's important for
us for you know s scientific uh yeah
it's true there's definitely a
workaround in this case yeah
yeah but there's also a method to verify
that would be different from from
choosing ahead of time the the the
integers and multiplying them and then
checking
sure
um so
um
already said this before okay um Quantum
proof or interactive proofs which we've
seen previously they they they give a
bit of a bootstrapping method in order
to verify uh Quantum Dynamics so that is
that if the experimentalist is satisfied
that she can completely characterize
control that she knows exactly what uh a
small Quantum system is for instance
three cubits then she can run an
interactive process with a remote uh for
the experiment in order to convince
herself that she controls the entire
Quantum
system and I actually looked up what a
bootstrap was and I thought it was kind
of cool that these straps on cowboy
boots okay um another application you
may have this in the back of your mind
kind of wondering what's the
relationship with a cryptographic
primitive that's that's had a lot of
attention recently a Quantum fully
homomorphic
encryption so this was a big open
question uh was open for about 30 years
and uh
uh Gentry gave the first solution in
2009 so um it's related to delegating
computations because it has to do with
encryp Computing on encrypted data so a
fully hom homor encryption scheme is a
public key encryption scheme that also
has an evaluation algorithm so basically
the evaluation algorithm uses the public
key and is able to uh evaluate a circuit
so or function f on Cipher texts such
that uh if you were to decrypt using the
secret key the result of the evaluation
function you would get the uh function
evaluated on the corresponding clear
texts so horor encryption gives a way of
delegating computations that are private
you know you can just encrypt your data
using the public key send it over to the
server server performs eval and then the
client can can perform the decryption
and get the output of the computation
and we um we require this compactness
requirement in in order to eliminate
trivial Solutions so the compactness
says that the length of the output of
eval should be independent of the
function
itself an open question
is is there a Quantum equivalent to
homomorphic encryption to fully
homomorphic
encryption there are um known solutions
for Quantum Computing on encrypted data
but they don't satisfy exactly a Quantum
equivalent of this definition in the
sense that it's important that uh the
clients work should be independent of
the size of the circuit and that's not
the case in currently known
protocols and um I think that in order
to uh answer this question we're going
to need new fundamental insights on
Computing on Quantum data and Computing
on encrypted Quantum
data okay another application of
delegated Quantum computations is device
Independence so in device Independence
um what happens is that a a party has
maybe think of it as a party has
purchased uh some computational devices
uh from a adal party so they don't trust
that the purchase that they've made
actually um follows what the seller
claims follow they follows so for
instance if you're trying to do Quantum
key distribution with some devices that
you bought from a specific company how
do you know that there's not a side
channel that outputs the key to um to
some uh third
party while using device Independence uh
it's possible to implement these
functionalities without having to trust
the devices themselves and we only rely
on the assumption that devices are
separated and they don't communicate so
again it's a bit of this cross
interrogation process that allows us to
uh gain certainty on the on the level of
security that we
want and um actually I'll go back so
it's been shown that delegated Quantum
computation gives us device independent
Quantum key distribution so uh it's
actually kind of if you can delegate
Quantum computations with a
classical client and Quantum servers and
be convinced of the answer
then you can have the quantum servers um
measure half epr Pairs and that gives
you a key that is
secret so it's actually kind of like a
complicated way so delegating
computations is a is you know it's
difficult in general very general a task
and then if you um limit it to
performing measuring epr pairs then you
get device independent Quantum key
distribution and an open question is
what else can we kind of rephrase in
terms of delegated Quantum computation
you know although we have ways of doing
um device independent qkd that's even
feasible and fault tolerant Etc can we
rephrase that in terms of delegated
Quantum computation or the other way
around could delegated Quantum Quantum
computation Give us new insights into
this device independent
um uh cryptographic task and are there
other cryptographic Primitives that
could benefit from relationships with
device
Independence okay so yet another
application uh onetime
programs a one-time
program can be seen as the following so
a sender and receiver uh have a joint
Quantum input as well as a uh the sender
knows of a Quantum
channel that she wants to encode into a
black box so um via a Quantum process
she uh does that and then she's able to
send the black box to the receiver who
at a later time can evaluate the channel
on this joint input row get the output
and then the box self-destructs so it's
one time in the sense that you can
evaluate this channel only
once and this was shown to be possible
um in the model where we allowed Quantum
information as well as uh classical
onetime
memories
so this is a bit different from
delegating computations because in this
case this party here the receiver which
uh takes the role of the server actually
now provides an input and receives an
output so in the delegated case it was
the client that provides the input and
gets the output so um we needed to
develop new techniques to deal with this
but um it is a form of delegating
computations give a sense of why one
would want to do that why would want to
do Quantum one time programs yeah oh um
so onetime programs would be useful for
uh digital Rights Management so you
maybe you buy a product and you can use
it
once coins things that you know that you
want them to expire after single
use and this is a very general scenario
it's like running a Quantum circuit but
maybe have more
specific circuits that you want to
do is it important that a state is
shared between the sender and receiver
um oh so this
picture um is the most General case
again so that uh they have this joint
input row and they want to evalate this
channel on a& B we just it's just the
most General possible way um actually
kind of admit that in my previous
pictures were not the most General but I
meant them to be this
actually okay so um a related um open
question related to runtime programs in
the sense that uh we're looking for a
functionality where the receiver
provides an input and gets the output is
um called program officiation yeah so I
can ask about the one time programs
again let's suppose that the sender and
receiver did not have an entangled input
so you just the sender Microsoft wants
to make a bunch of software programs
that the receiver can evaluate on their
own thing and they want to package up
then package is it correct to say the
package would include a Quantum State
together with a classical onetime memory
and you could just sort of put that in
the mail and then you know not interact
any more in the receiver would use it
yes okay yes um for the benefit of
others the question was uh you know if
the uh if there's no joint if I if IOD
correctly if there's if this isn't a
joint entangled State um what would the
onetime program look like so you know
remove this and there's maybe just an
input and or maybe not even an input put
maybe there a channel that you want to
hide and then in that case the onetime
program would look like class Quantum
States as well as classical onetime
memories which are actually modeled
after one2
TS oblivious
transfers okay so uh open problem is a
Quantum program alisation so Quantum
program alisation would allow a receiver
similarly to evaluate a channel um where
where the receiver doesn't know the
channel so the channel would kind of be
hidden um but it doesn't have this
onetime properties so it's more like the
it could be possible to run run multiple
times but um but it should not be
possible to uh extract too much
information about this Quantum channel
five so there's multiple definitions for
program alisation but uh one that was
used in a classical impossibility proof
um by Barat G and all these other
authors uh so they have this
impossibility proof saying it's actually
not possible to uh do program alisation
the proof doesn't hold in the quantum
case because of the no cloning theorem
so they have this little part of this
proof that they kind of assume that they
can copy information well that's not the
case for Quantum States so um so it's an
open problem whether we could do program
alisation this is the end of the uh
first part of my talk that talks about
you know General overview applications
so it's a good time to kind of pause for
questions if anybody is
wondering y go back slide one slide the
program obervation so I think recently
there have been some positive result C
about this yeah so so how does that
relate to this so the the current uh
recent positive results on classical
program officiation had to do with using
a different security definition so it's
called indistinguishability officiation
so they showed that it was possible so
um so it doesn't contradict this
impossibility it just has to do with I
you know definitions and actually I just
wondering what's your definition of the
quantum program modification so do you
change the whole model or change part of
it so what's the defin what's the
definition of the quantum program
application that we'd be looking for
here well in order to make it you know
the most um interesting result we could
we could try to use the uh impos the
definition that was used in impos
impossibility result which was a
simulation based uh definition so we
could uh take a Quantum version of that
and then try to show that that would be
possible okay I can't remember another
result maybe I'm I'm wrong I think there
some result by U Jordan and some other
source about some negative result on
quation Stacey was on that paper I think
and
uh negative result um negative result we
had proposal for but there's not really
anything rigorous to
say so it's I think it was if I can kind
of summarize I was using some
intermediate security definition with uh
uh heuristic proofs
yeah yeah it was her istic so it
wouldn't kind of necessarily fit into
this mole right
away yeah another question um yeah I
just I'm not very familiar with this
what is just classical program operation
and how is that different from like
homomorphic
encryption what's class school program
alisation and how's that different from
fully homomorphic
encryption can I have another
hour um
well okay program alisation by the way
you also have markers there if you want
to use them just thanks thanks oh this
is the white board okay
um okay so I think of program
officiation as a uh you know a way to
hide the source code of your uh
program so maybe you've developed this
cool new Java appet and you don't want
people to know how it actually runs but
you want them to to be able to run
it
okay um and fully homor encryption is
that you want to benefit from remote
resources that can do computations for
you but you don't want to R the data so
you want to encrypt it before sending it
over to the
server so they both have a flavor of
Delegation this one is a bit more
farfetched than the other
one data encrypted versus program is
enced well that makes it sound really
trivial because there's a you know via
Universal circuits you can kind of get
from one to the other it's also
fundamentally that the receiver in
officiation provides input and gets
output in fully homework encryption it's
the sender or the client that provides
input and gets output so um I think
that's easier it's a lot easier than to
deal with the cheating party provides
the input and gets the output and gets
harder okay um any other further
questions about applications and stuff
like
that um if not we're going to move on to
specific methods to delegate quantum
comput
and I have uh three in mind we'll see
how far we can get um and they're kind
of an increasing level of difficulty
perhaps especially with regards to the
first one is quantum Computing on
encrypted data so we just want to um
have privacy the second one Quantum
Computing on authenticated data so we
want to have
verifiability and the third one is well
now we really want a fully classical
client in order to do this we can um if
we postulate multiple servers we can do
it so how to do
that Quantum Computing on encrypted
data actually has a relatively long
history starting uh 2005 so
um now uh we'll imagine that the client
before sending her data to the server
encrypts it with some sort of key K and
then there's interaction of perhaps the
key needs to be updated to key to K
Prime and the client knows what that
keyk Prime is um and at the end she can
decrypt it and get the result of the
computation um and they're depending on
if you use the child's result or a more
recent result called Quantum Computing
on encrypted data so this was a joint
Theory and experimental paper um so
child's result uh requires more
resources from the client point of view
uh and then we've reduced this to
sending random bb84 cubits um
and I'll show you how so
um I kind of suppose that everybody's
familiar with universal gate set so the
channel uh will now be we'll assume that
we have a circuit description of the
channel uh using this uh gate set of
poly Clifford and then this Pi over8
gate or R will be the non Clifford group
gate and then um we'll use this
decomposition in the protocol itself
we'll also use an encryption scheme and
the the um
most obvious encryption scheme if you
want information theoretic or
statistical Security will be the onetime
pad and in the quantum case the quantum
One Time Pad uh involves randomizing the
quantum state with a random poly uh
operator so a random X and a random Zed
so the key has two classical bits A and
B and here is a highle description of
the
protocol you should see you should kind
of Imagine imagine what's going on that
the client has an input
row and she starts by encrypting it with
these random Poes and then these uh
red uh exponents are the actual
key and then she sends her data to the
server and will um write on each wire
the corresponding key such that if she
were to decrypt these wires she would
get the
um
uh data at that point in the
computation and then there's going to be
little gadgets kind of subprotocols for
each of these potential uh circuit
components so for instance we we want to
do an argate while we go into this sub
subprotocol and at the end of the
subprotocol the client has updated her
knowledge of the key so
far uh and Etc we have two Cubit Gates
slightly more
complicated and we'll just keep on going
oops um at the end the uh the server uh
Returns the output to the client who can
decrypt the output and get the result of
the
computation and uh well for the client
to prepare single cubits and to do
measurements is relatively easy so this
one just sets the key to be zero and if
you want to do a computational basis
measurement then uh the b key so the the
the exponent of the Zed encryption
doesn't matter at all so you can just
throw that out and then when you get a
classical bit out of the measurement
result all you have to um use to decrypt
it would be the classical uh key for the
X poly
Matrix and
um it's not that hard to do uh all these
Clifford group Gates on encrypted data
so actually this is by definition the
Clifford group um is a set of operators
that conjugate poly operators into poly
operators so there's always a key update
rule if you apply a Clifford group gate
okay get they get slightly more
complicated here but it's it's possible
so the only problem you run into is when
you want to do a non- Clifford group
gate on on the encrypted
data and uh what happens if you work it
out is if you do this pyate gate on
encrypted data you get this key update
rule that includes a p this is this is a
phase gate and this is not you don't
want this um so how do you get rid of
that well uh child has this idea that
let's use quantum interaction in order
to get the server to undo this
pate so here's what happens the data
wire is encrypted here the server does
the argate with the potential P error um
sends it back to the client who decrypts
it and then she's going to send either
send the server a dummy
Cubit or send him the real Cubit
depending on whether or not P should be
applied or not and but the server is not
going to find out because the Cubit will
be encrypted he always does p no matter
what and returns it and then the client
can decrypt it so this requires from the
client point of view to be able to do a
swap gate as well as a Quantum
interaction in order to exchange this
Quantum
register and uh the question was well is
this really
necessary is this Quantum interaction
required and uh the answer is no so in
recent results it was shown that um the
server can be can be led to correct this
error this P error um using an an
auxiliary Cubit that's independent of
the computation as well as classical
interaction only and this can be done
via the circuit here which is looks a
bit daunting it's inspired by uh kind of
gate teleportation and the circuit
manipulation
techniques and
um well yeah people are kind of falling
asleep so I think I'll just kind of skip
this quickly and say that uh
the um what goes on is we use this
auxiliary Cubit use this classical data
and uh the net effect is that the server
applies this correction if and only if
it had to um and there is classical
communication in the sense of returning
this classical bit and this is the key
update rule that the uh client needs to
take into
account okay uh security so it's Rel
yeah you presented um as far as I
understood you presented that there was
this issue that for you'd have this
extra P that you couldn't sort of update
or you couldn't
somehow uh ecrypt is that the extra P
doesn't fit into the you know it's not a
key it's just this extra error that we
need to get rid of because it doesn't we
want the we want them to be only poly uh
operations so just just encryptions
right so so without necessarily going
into detail can you what's the main idea
for how that how you managed to do that
okay yeah in this in this circuit well
what the main idea of how I managed to
do this and thanks thanks for quite of
letting me focus on what I wanted to to
say here is that there's an xly Cubit
that is sent by the client to the server
that has a hidden p in it so this is
random it's a hidden p and then it's
then it's red after that and this uh
this is this Randomness is sufficient
such that the uh server will do a p
correction but it'll be a random from
his point of view he doesn't know uh if
it's a meaningful correction or if it's
just kind of unding this random one here
and he does this P conditioned on a
classical um bit X that he receives from
the client so everything is kind of uh
works together the quantum uh auxiliary
Cubit and the classical
bit such that uh he'll be undoing the P
only if he needed to but he's not going
to find out if it was if a was equal to
one or
zero does that kind of help a bit okay
um security so it's intuitively clear so
we're using encrypted
data so it should be secure right but
there's interaction in this protocol uh
so how do you define security how do you
say well that um
you know what are you trying to prove
and then how do you prove it and how do
you formalize it the server learns
nothing via this interaction this is
done via uh techniques established in
modern cryptography um which generally
have to do with simulation based
security
definitions so we look at the real
protocol here which is the interaction
between the client and the
server and consider S Prime being any
deviating
server
and then we look at this Ideal World
which has to do with a simulator so the
simulator depends on the deviating
server that you've chosen but note that
the simulator here doesn't interact it
doesn't even it doesn't get the client's
input it only gets the same input that
uh the server the server gets in this
world here and if for every possibly
cheating uh server there exists such a
simulator such that these two channels
are indistinguishable then we'll say
that the original protocol was Secure
sorry can
you you try that one more time yeah try
that one more time okay
so you look at the actual protocol and
what's going on in the actual protocol
let s Prim be any deviating server so
think about try to think about this as
the most malicious surver you could come
up with and it has an it has an output
here right
so it might be able to extract
information about the private you know
about the client's private uh data and
output it here that would be bad that
would be very
bad this Ideal World here is secure by
definition it is a simulator or whatever
a party just a map that doesn't have
access to the client's input so how
could it possibly cheat it can't you
know it just gets the input of the
server it doesn't have any
no communication whatsoever so this has
to be secured by
definition it just it's just a map that
takes uh you know its input and output
something so if for every possible
cheating server here there exists a
simulator such that these two maps are
indistinguishable you know this one is
secure by definition so if it's
indistinguishable from this one well
then this one must have been secure to
start
with yeah and there a for for Row in is
that sort of a for all possible Row in
yes for all possible Row in because I'm
talking about Maps so it is for
yes so you could also just say that fee
has no
dependence on
the uh on the C part of the
input maybe but okay yeah yeah so that
would be a you know an intuitive way of
doing I don't know how to formalize that
but that indeed we want to show that you
know this map has this output at least
has no dependence on this part of the
input yeah and there's interaction in
this protocol too so you know gets
complicated so that's computational in
distinguishability or oh thanks so um
this is a general picture but uh we're
working with statistical so uh
statistical and distinguishability but
it can be applicable if you're looking
for a computationally secure protocol
so in the um statistical
distinguishability for for Quantum Maps
is called Diamond
Norm yeah in this protocol how do the
resources of the client compare to the
resources of that's required by the uh
in the protocol the resources of the
client um that we've looked
at um the best one that that we know of
the client has to generate these uh
auxiliary cupit which are a unitary
equivalent to bb84 States so plus minus
Z and one and the server has a full
quantum
computer the the server client also has
Classical computation do you have one of
these bb84 states for every R yes
exactly yeah one auxiliary States for
every R state for every R
gate so um so this is a security
definition uh the proof uh I'm just
going to say that um there's a very nice
proof technique to uh take the original
protocol convert it to a protocol that
uses entanglement so we don't want
entanglement in the final protocol
because that's complicated but as a
proof technique we'll convert it to a
protocol that uses entanglement and that
protocol will be trivially secure so
then you can kind of and then you can um
argue indistinguishability between the
various protocols and then go back to
the original protocol and say that it
was
Secure sorry so having having used that
as the proof technique is that really
how you see it or or do you now that now
that it's all put together do you see it
in some other way so I see entangle uh I
see um encrypted cubits as half epr
pairs that's kind of that proof
technique has kind of changed my way of
viewing uh encrypted data but that's
about
it so so you see encrypted cubits say
half e
yeah um this this this line of work is
related to what's called Blind Quantum
Computing that historically came between
the child's protocol and the one that
we've just talked about uh the main
purpose was to hide the uh computation
being performed uh but as I already
mentioned there's a easy translation
between um using Universal circuits
between hiding the computation itself
and hiding the
data this blind Quantum Computing was
developed in the measurement based model
for Quantum computation requires a
little bit more Quantum Resources from
the client and needs to able to prepare
uh random cubits chosen from a set of
eight possible
cubits and there's been a lot of
follow-up work on blind Quantum
Computing and this is just a sample of
it so is there a a summary of where
things
stand like a written up summary of where
things stand two sentence summary I
don't know I don't really know what to
say a summary on where things stand you
know there's been work on what's the
power of required of the client there's
one like with measurement where Alice
only needs to be able to measure
cubits there's different results on uh
did I even include it here no on uh
composability the composable security of
this protocol uh there's
experimental uh
demonstrations so I don't think I can
summarize this in just a few know just
one phrase I
yeah
um so the next protocol I want to talk
about is verifiability and it can be
seen as adding adding an extra layer of
encoding in order to be able to verify
the
computation very much related to the
previous one but just let's just like
make the encoding not just an encryption
but something a bit more complicated in
order to provide a verification
mechanism and again the client wants to
be able to verify even though she can't
do the computation herself so this is
kind of
neat okay so the main idea is tamper
proof
computation the client is going to send
an encoding of the input and the exer
cubits are also going to be
encoded the encoding is tamper proof in
the sense that man uh any changes are
detected but it's maleable in the sense
that the server should be able to
perform Gates on the encoded on the
encoding okay and uh the encoding itself
will be uh what's called Quantum
authentication codes
and you should think about this as an
error detecting code that catches almost
all errors necessarily there's going to
be a key because this is a cryptographic
scenario so the key is going to kind of
hide which errors are not going to be
caught um and then in order to perform
Gates on the Cher proof en coding we're
going to use a method called Quantum
Computing on authenticated data you
should think about this as an analog to
fault tolerant Quantum Computing but on
data that's been encoded with for
champer proof encoding
the qcat is going to require auxiliary
cubits that the client is going to
prepare as well as classical interaction
between the client and the
server and qad was used for the first
time in the context of quantum
multiparty
computation okay we're going to use as
an authentication code something called
encode and encrypt so we're going to
encode the data and then encrypt it
using a random
poly the advantage of this is that the
random po actually breaks down the
attack into a conx combination of poly
attacks so all we have to do is deal
with poly
attacks so
um I'm not going to go into details of
this but uh we we've developed like this
simpler authentication code I think
anyways that uh has that we call the
Trap code so um you take the data you
encode it into an error detecting code
then you append these uh auxiliary
cubits that are traps zeros or pluses
and then apply a random permutation and
the key is the random permutation
itself and so it's kind of intuitively
clear that this is an authentication
code now to check it you just apply the
inverse of the permutation and then you
measure these traps in their respective
basis and if they all accept then you
accept and then now we need a method to
perform Gates on this data and uh this
is done using uh gadgets kind of like
what we saw in the previous protocol and
um well yeah I'll just say that these
gadgets require um some interaction and
also auxiliary
cubits and they're kind of inspired by
fault toing Quantum Computing and gate
teleportation so the protocol for
Quantum Computing on encrypted on
authenticated data is that the client
authenticates her data and the auxiliary
cubits sends them uh then there's
interaction to execute these gadgets and
now we have the same problem like how do
you define security and how do you prove
security security and um the most
General Security definition that makes
this protocol as useful as possible um
is called a a composable security
definition or universally
composable and this is what has been
done so um and this also postulates a
real world an Ideal World and shows that
these two are
indistinguishable and um I also just
want to mention that you know
intuitively security is clear because
you're Computing on authenticated data
so it should be verifiable but then
again there's interaction and how do you
fit that into the security proof well
this is actually shown to be totally
non-trivial
um I'll just stop there for that
um the next delegated Quantum
computation that I want to mention is
uh is uh you want the client to be
totally
classical and we'll do this with two
provs because we don't know how to do it
with only one
pro and uh this has been done using very
different techniques although you know
certainly they're related but how
they're related exactly is still an open
question so
um the chsh game so this is the game uh
a verifi here that's e well a verifier
provides questions to Alice and Bob and
they need to provide these are just bits
and they need to provide answer bits
such that the uh xor of the outputs
should equal to the uh multiplication or
the end of the inputs and uh you know
it's really well known in Quantum
information that
um Quantum devices can win this game
more often than classical devices so
they can win about 85% of the time
classical devices can win at most 75% of
the time and uh the strategy to use a
shared erpr
pair so this is a very rudimentary test
of quantumness you know you you do the
chsh game and
um the question is can we scale this
up just realized I'm missing the
reference here oh the reference was on
the previous slide here okay the
question is can we scale this up uh in
order to uh characterize a larger
Quantum systems or or further Quantum
operations and the answer uh is yes so
if we do a sequence of n
CS chsh games um and You observe that
the servers win close to the optimal
fraction of the
games then the theorem says that they
must have been acting according to
something close to a tensor product of
the ideal
strategies so this is this is very
powerful
because it gives you a way to
characterize the um Quantum actions of
these
servers so what's been done is that um
in order to take this and make it into
ACH into verifiable delegated Quantum
computation you combine various
subprotocols so either the players are
or the provs are doing a CHS game or
they're doing something called state
state tomography which kind of
characterizes the system that they're
they're operating on or they're doing
process tomography which characterizes
the channels that they're executing or
they're doing the actual computation
that you want them to do via a gate
teleportation type of
technique so there's these four
scenarios and uh the point is that from
this party's point of view these two
scenarios are the same and these two are
the same it's the same operations that
the verifier will ask them to do and for
the other party these two are the same
and these two are the same so they're
forced to behave identically in these uh
in these indistinguishable protocols and
we can use that to um you know you
confirm here the state their
entanglement the state the process and
you use this uh information to gain a
confidence on the fact that uh the
portion that's doing the computation is
doing the computation
correctly okay so uh this is the end of
my talk usually I would kind of talk
about open questions and give a pers
perspective but that was the entire
first part of the talk so instead I'll
just give this table that summarizes the
three uh protocols that we've talked
about for computing on encrypted
authenticated data or the uh rigidity of
the chsh game
protocol we have time for some
questions
yeah this en Computing on encrypted data
you said it was like a theory
experimental paper what were some of the
experimental results so the uh quum
computer on encrypted data was a theory
and experimental paper and uh the theory
was the protocol the proof and all that
and what was the experimental results
well it was that we were the we were
able to build it so
um uh they were um using uh Optics
and
um uh it was possible to implement
um the the basic gate Set uh having a re
and with a reasonable Fidelity so the
Big Challenge was to do this R gate uh
this non-ford group gate and that that
required uh you know two cubid
interactions and uh I was shown that it
was still possible to do it and and it
was the first time that was a
relatively you know this's always was a
divide between the experimental security
and the theoretical security but I would
say it's the first time that there's a
relatively um reasonable level of
security in the in the protocol because
there was this active switching of uh
you know all changing the encryption
between the runs of the of the of the
experiment who who were the
experimentalists who were the
experimentalists so where which where
were they so was it in iqc University of
watero
who only wrote once the entire names
because
this so there was the the main the first
author is the um graduate
student uh Kent fiser and it was um in
the lab of um Kevin rush so fiser
broadman
sh Yan LA prevel yine and
Rush
I don't know why it takes some seven
people to this device
that there were some technical
problems so U just a vague question
what what would be a ambitious but
possibly realistic next result ambitious
but possibly realistic next
result I'm really excited about hph
fully homomorphic
encryption and program
alisation um and you and and you believe
they're both your intuition is that they
should both be do yeah
yeah I have a similar question that so
is there a master result like saying
that there is a protocol where uh like
the server does not learn anything the
the verifier can verify the verifier can
like knows that what's going so is there
like a like an ultimate result that we
can hope for or there is no such thing
ultimate you that can hopeful hope
for I don't know the the multiple server
with a classical client gets pretty
close to that you know it's fully
classical than multiple servers uh if is
it possible with only classical
server like no for delegated
computations because the input could be
quantum so you kind of have to have
something Quantum but maybe for
classical computations yeah so the fully
classical client and Quantum polinomial
time server you know qpip with a fully
classical client that's B question so
the server is always Quantum right yes
and the and the client is either Quantum
or or classical well you want some sort
of restriction on on Quantum but the
client is
classical and um
but there is also the security aspect so
for instance in the last result you
explained there is absolutely no
security aspect you just want to verify
that the servers do what they are
supposed to do well that's a security
aspect um yeah but they can learn the I
mean they can learn your output and they
can oh yeah I I didn't I didn't mention
that but it so happens that it is also
secure in in the Privacy uh
realm but the goal was verifiability U
yeah classically you can have
verifiability without privacy but I
think that quantumly that's not the
case and all right oh uh uh this is a
question along the same lines but for
this um this open question about qpip
being equal to
bqp are there any proposed
protocols that can't be proven secure is
that no one even has an idea about how
one would uh run yes so for a fully
classical verifier and the qpip protocol
nothing's been proposed I don't think
it's true okay I don't really see how
you can do that
but know the best you could hope for I
would say would
be the pro the the verifier having the
capability of maybe any two non nonoral
States maybe that would be
optimal
but okay so if there are more questions
let's thank an
again and we'll start again after lunch
at
1:30